Speaker 1: Televangelist Christian demagogue
Pat Robertson has passed away at the age of
93.
The Associated Press reporting Pat Robertson,
broadcaster who helped make religion central
to Republican politics, dies at 93, a man
we have covered for a very, very long time,
founder of the Christian Broadcasting Network,
the 700 Club.
For more than half a century, he was known
for his 700 club television show.
Now, as I said, when Rush Limbaugh passed
away, and as I said, when we've seen the deaths
of many different figures, I don't wish death
upon anyone.
These individuals, to the extent that they
have family and friends and loved ones, they
are loved, they are missed.
People are grieving and that is their absolute
right and privilege.
And also I can recognize that in their public
life they were extraordinarily damaging to
the country and to the world.
And Pat Robertson was one of the most damaging
religious influences in America of the last
50 years, part of the movement that's stuffed
and stuffed and stuffed religiosity into civil
government.
And the Republican Party wanted a Christian
version of Sharia law.
This is the reality.
One little highlight for you here is Pat Robertson
at the in the earlier phases of when the country
was going in the direction of saying, hey,
listen, like gay marriage, not a big deal,
etc., apocalyptically stating that it will
bring the judgment of God on the nation and
we will be vomited out by the land.
If the Equality Act passes.
Speaker 2: Let them know that you are opposed
to what is called the religious orders.
The Equality Act is just it is of course it's
it's got a name and all.
They always give the good names to these things.
This is a devastating blow to religious freedom
and to the sanctity of America.
If you want to bring the judgment of God on
this nation, you should keep this stuff up.
You know, I was reading in Leviticus, which
is because of these things, the land of Violently
Wild, right, Harmony, New World, I think God
will say, I've had it with America.
If you do this kind of stuff, I'm willing
to get rid of you as a nation.
Then, you know, there's plenty of stuff that's
going on.
When you look at.
Speaker 1: That so super scary stuff, you
will get vomited out.
I do want to remind everybody, there is a
very long list of things that Pat Robertson
during his storied career said are demonic
or potentially demonic.
Remember that demons can attach themselves.
This is from Pat Robertson.
I can't play all of these clips, but you can
find them in our archives.
Second hand sweaters can have demonic attachment,
Ouija boards, yoga, Harry Potter, feng shui,
karate, horoscopes, The Twilight series, paintings
of Buddha TV shows about ghosts can be demonic.
Halloween Absolutely demonic psychics can
be demonic.
When young girls levitate their friends at
sleepovers that can be demonic.
And sometimes adopted children from other
countries can be demonic.
According to Pat Robertson, We also had this
absolutely classic, classic moment where Pat
Robertson said even little babies just out
of the womb could conceivably be demonic as
well.
Remember this?
Speaker 2: Amen.
All right.
Here's the caller, Lisa from Fallon in Nevada.
My question is regarding demon possession.
Ten babies possessed.
And if so, does the age of accountability
come into play for salvation?
Right.
You asked what age can babies be possessed,
and if so, does the age of accountability
come into play for salvation?
Well, the age of accountability has to do
at the point, you know, right from wrong.
And that normally doesn't take place to you're
old enough to understand something's wrong.
So the age of accountability can be five.
It can be 62 before it could be three.
But kill a baby, be demon possessed.
I just believe if that child is born to a
family of devil worshipers, there's a real
possibility that the devil will think that
he has a claim over the child.
I mean, it's horrible to contemplate, but.
Speaker 1: You know.
Speaker 2: I don't think.
Speaker 1: He doesn't take pleasure in giving
us this news.
But yeah, babies can come out of the womb
demon possessed.
So 93 year old Pat Robertson passing away
an incredible legacy, which I think is a negative
one.
And we will leave it there.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after this.